foreign
[Music]
so
I do want to play a Chicago London game
unfortunately yesterday or the last
Speed Run game where I tried to do that
my opponent played G6 so we ended up
transposing to a modern with E4 here
hopefully we get an opportunity to play
the tripava and we will and we will
we play the jababa London hopefully I
don't make a fool of myself Asics is one
of the more common moves I would say
along with E6 and Bishop F5 it's like
the main Trifecta I almost put G6 in a
separate category because it's a
completely different type of position
that you get a lot the lines A6 E6
Bishop F5 and 2 in certain extent C6 all
lead to pretty similar positions which
the the kind of commonality is that the
jibaba London appears very innocuous it
doesn't appear all that dangerous it
doesn't seem like an attacking opening
but all of that is an illusion it's
actually a very very aggressive system
and a lot of people get in trouble
because they don't realize how vast
White's attacking potential is so we
respond with E3 this is a move that you
always make in the jabalon C5 is already
a mistake right another example of how
tricky the jababa London is C5 is an
attempt to punish us for developing our
Knight to C3 because in the London
system the tradition London when You
Face them with C5 you typically respond
with C3 you build the pawn triangle so
that D4 is well defended but the great
thing about putting the Knight on C3 is
that you're exerting immediate pressure
on the D5 Pawn that means that there is
a move to play here that you don't often
play in the traditional London now the
reason it this move makes sense here is
because after this move the pressure on
D5 intensifies and it makes it harder
for black to win back the pawn of course
I'm implying that the move is D take C5
and it is surprisingly problematic for
black to win back this Pawn without
falling behind a development Knight C6
is the most common response and you may
think
you may think that the automatic
response to that is Knight to F3 this is
where getting the course yields a lot of
benefits Knight F3 is not the correct
move here even though it's by far the
most common Move online the correct move
is A3 now the idea of A3 should be very
obvious to everybody we want to play B4
and secure the pawn on C5 but the flaw
inherent in this move seems to be the
blackplay Z5 grabs control of the center
and then wins The Pawn on C5 with
interest
but there is a catch rather than meekly
dropping back to G3 we put the bishop on
G5 and now the power of our Knight
development really shines through we're
threatening the very simple Bishop takes
F6 and Knight takes D5 which would knock
out a key Central Pawn and retain our
material advantage black has to waste
the tempo playing Bishop E6 what does
this give us the opportunity to do
well this gives us the opportunity now
to secure the C5 Pawn with a move before
and that's why we played A3 white is up
upon for no compensation okay now we're
exiting the opening stage and we're
entering the middle game stage and we
have to be accurate
so because we spent a couple of Tempe
crafting our Pawn structure on the queen
side we have fallen behind and
development a little bit so we need to
remedy that so the obvious move would be
Knight to F3 another typical idea in
these lines is to transfer the knight
from C3 to B6 so Knight A4 is a move
that you see very often in this line I
don't see the rush I don't see the need
to do that immediately we'll have to
check the course afterward to make sure
I'm getting the move order right but I'm
pretty sure that the move is Knight to
F3 black typically castles and we
continue our development not with Bishop
to D3 that walks right into the fork but
the bishop is developed more modestly to
E2 that's it we're up a full Pawn
and more importantly it's not just any
pawn this Pawn makes it difficult for
black to breathe right it's just
controlling squares that black would
like to use to get his pieces into the
game more efficiently a lot of people go
Queen D7 in a position like this then
the effectiveness of Knight A4 is
increased hopefully you see why because
once the Knight hits B6 that's actually
a fork at the very least it'll come with
tempo
so I would say that the compensation is
very limited because just having more
Pawns in the center does not yield
competition there's a question in the
chat from peculiar estate would you
really say there's no compensation black
is a better Center and fairly classical
development
so we also have classical development
right the pieces are actually developed
very similarly if you compare the
placement of the knights the placement
of these two Bishops basically develop
in a symmetrical the only big difference
that black has more Pawns in the center
but both of these pawns are also
liabilities we're attacking and
pressuring both pawns with our Knights
our Pawn on E3 is doing the job it's
restricting the mobility of black spawns
it's making the move d4 a lot less
dangerous than it otherwise would be
it's like a speed bump right that's not
really allowing the car to accelerate if
black plays D4 then we would likely snap
off the pawn we would trade once and
then we would Garner the E4 Square for
our Knight by first taking on F6 then
sticking our Knight in the center on e4
Queen E8 I mean that is
a tricky move it sets a trap that I'm
seeing through already the Trap that it
sets is if Bishop takes F6 Bishop takes
F6 Knight takes D5
what you should notice is the alignment
of Black's bishop and White's rook in
the corner so black has this move E4 but
not immediately because immediately we
would we would take the bishop on F6
the problem is block first takes on D5
then plays E4 that's a discovered attack
against the Knight we do have Knight D4
in that position but if you keep
calculating black can take on D4 and
then finally play Rook d8 and win the D4
Pawn back with interest I'm not
interested in these kinds of tactics
because we're simply up a pawn let's
proceed
simply and I will show this over the
board after the game so don't worry okay
we there's no reason for us not to
Castle clearly our opponent wants to put
a rook on d8 and x-ray Our Queen and
maybe prepare the move d4 no 94 okay did
I blunder I might have Blended whoa
whoa what is 94. I did wonder this move
oh my gosh
wow Queen E8 is unbelievable and the
idea is Knight E4 I didn't see that
I didn't see that that at all that is
not in the course needless to say Knight
takes C4 d e Bishop B7 the idea is EF I
mean we're not worse I think position is
equal
position is equal
but that's brilliant by our opponent and
I'm learning new things about the line
so basically what did I miss if the
queen was still on d8 then we would be
able to take the bishop on E7 and we
would be attacking the queen so black
wouldn't have to spend that Tempo
recapturing the bishop now we can't do
that so while I still have to take on E7
white black now takes on F3 I have to
take the Rook black takes we take and at
the end of the day we get two Pawns in a
rook for two minor pieces so we're still
I would probably prefer white here but
definitely I should have seen that still
I think white is doing completely fine
now when you have a rook against two
pieces we haven't had too many of these
games in the speed run so I think it's a
good thing the evaluation of two a rook
for two pieces type situations depends
primarily on the relative activity of
the Rook versus the minor pieces so if
you're the side of the Rook or the two
Rooks you have to aim for total Rook
activity ASAP so in this case the move
is a no-brainer we need to put something
on D1 that's the only open file I
propose that we've put the F Rook on D1
so that the Rook on A1 kind of
supervised some of these Queen side
Pawns
like if black plays A5 or something it's
a good idea I think to keep one of the
Rooks on the queen side for the time
being I'm also eyeing the juicy D6
Square for our Rook we can stick a rook
on D6 and we can use that as a Anchor
Point and then double Rooks on the D
file still I think white is doing
completely fine here after the game
we'll check exactly where I went wrong I
mean castles is kind of a mini blunder
but I'm I'm just stunned by this idea
Queen E8 and 94.
incredible
so still I think white is doing fine
here
yeah Rook D6 is ultimately the idea
suddenly our opponent is finally
thinking
which is
been pretty rare thus far I actually
think black's position is hard to play
partially because the Knight on C6 is
fully restricted
we're controlling D4 we're controlling
B4
the bishop on E6 is fine but it has no
jumping off points
yeah it's it's not as much of a blunder
as I thought it was sort of a visceral
reaction I thought it was a blunder but
now when I look at this position I like
white a lot I think if black handles
this well it should be closer to equal
The Rook trade is probably good for us
as a general rule of thumb and this is
very general if there is a situation two
Rooks versus two minor pieces in a rook
a trait of a pair of Rooks favors the
side with the Rook a lot of situations
where it's pure Rook versus two minor
pieces and there are no other pieces on
the board The Rook often dominates
simply because the Rook has long range
ability and the bishop and the Knights
long range ability to Ferry it's from
side to side is restricted so The Rook
often trampolines from one side of the
board to the other and wins a bunch of
Pawns because the minor pieces are just
incompetent at defending weaknesses I
think this is an excellent move that our
opponent just played because this opens
up a square for the night
yeah this is not going to be an easy
game I can already
oh wow Rook d695 Rook D1 there's Bishop
G4 okay
I think we should start by sticking The
Rook on D6 this is kind of something
that we can just sort of do
but after 95 assuming that that's what
our opponent wants we have to think a
little bit
yeah diocoro is very strong
Queen E7 okay
so well in the absence of all things
held equal our next move would be Rook a
to D1 I think that's what we should do
is there any tactical issue with that no
Queen G5 yes this is actually very very
good play by black
this is exactly how I think black should
play this
so maybe it's a good idea to make it
difficult for black to play
Queen
to G5 so the move Queen to H5 comes to
mind but then black can stick the queen
on F6 and infiltrate B2
actually I have some tricks in mind
so let's go
let's go Queen H5
and the point of Queen H5 I'm stopping
Queen G5 and the reason I'm scared of
Queen G5 is because it aims at the G2
pawn and black has these annoying
threats like Bishop H3 and Bishop G4 to
F3
now maybe it wasn't as dangerous as I
made it out to be but I'm trying to kind
of jostle for for good spots for our
pieces I'm trying to make it difficult
for our opponent to coordinate as much
as possible using our
uh using what we have at our disposal
which is not a lot
yeah H6 but that doesn't do much I mean
I if I were playing Black I would make
some lufts but that but that is very
advanced
yeah black resign our opponent resigned
his last three games in Zero moves okay
that's reassuring
okay let's go Rook D1 let's double on
the D file
there's no question I'm I'm getting
outplayed for now but that could change
Rook f8
okay I fully understand that move
I guess our opponent is basically saying
that white has no ways to infiltrate
that's the biggest problem in our
position is that I just can never play
Rogue D7 because the bishop is guarding
that score so basically
White's ability to improve their
position is restricted we just have to
sit and wait but if we're sitting and
waiting I might as well make some
helpful moves so one thing I really want
to do is make some left for my own King
we're gonna go H3
and this is going to help in situations
where
you know where the Rooks start
journeying to Black side of the board
and Etc
yeah this is I'm apprehensive about this
position but there's plenty of Chess
left to be played plenty of Chess left
to be playing yeah he's this guy is
playing GM level for now but
you know flares we have reached a level
where people are capable of playing
really really good chess for prolonged
periods of time maybe not for the entire
game that would make it a little bit
weird but for very long periods of time
all right Queen e84 has me shook this
idea is wild
this might be the first time I've seen
this type of pattern ever
okay but we're playing reasonable moves
this is going to be a great
advertisement for the chababa course I'm
going to lose my first speedrun game in
the jababa and that's going to be the
ultimate advertisement for the course
no at five I would love to see if he
plays F5 I'd be really happy the move F5
in this position it weakens the bishop
tremendously and remember that the
bishop is what's holding Black's
position together because if it moves
yeah that's what precisely what I was
afraid of
okay so I I am I'm getting this feeling
of help of hopelessness but we're still
gonna try
I'm starting to get that feeling of
hopelessness I have a an idea which is
to play C4
this was my intended move for a long
time because I'm trying to push through
B5 and get these pawns rolling as much
as possible
there's a lot of ways that black can
mess this up for example I think 90.
okay that's not one of them but actually
wait this one
we went to H4
I thought I have Queen to H4 and I'm
counter-attacking the E4 Pawn
I think
maybe white is fine here
and I probably miscalculating something
I'm finally I'm I'm at least I'm posing
some problems he's getting a little bit
low on time although 950 is a lot of
time
okay so basically the idea of Queen H4
is I'm waiting for black to take on A3
and then I'll play B5
and I'll Attack the Knight and then at
the right moment I'll play Queen takes
E4 I've calculated some nice lines here
oh for instance Queen A3 B5 the good
thing is the Rooks are doubled otherwise
black would be able to take on C5 but
then we take the Knight so Queen takes
A3 B5
bang bang let's say black plays Knight
to E5 then we play Queen takes C4 and in
that position if black plays Knight
takes C4 who can tell me what tactical
move I've cooked up as a response so
queen a3b595 queen E4 Knight C4 what is
my intention that yeah rookie six very
good Rook takes C6 there because the
bishop is defending the Knight on C4 and
the queen is making contact with it and
if F takes E6 we could even take the
pawn to with check first and then come
back and take the Knight we'd be up two
Pawns
um so that's kind of the Tactical
justification there's some other cool
lines
Queen takes A3
first off if black takes the other way I
don't think he's gonna do that that
would not be a very
uh understandable okay Queen takes a
three we play B5 so I'm trying to play a
little bit quickly here because he took
two minutes on this last move if he does
that like three more times we're in
business
we're totally in business so Queen takes
A3 played now the Knight has to decide
where it's going if black takes on B5
then we take back and I'm happy because
our pawns are undoubled
so if I were playing Black I would
probably move the Knight but this is
exceedingly complicated position
this is an exceedingly complicated
position okay he does take interesting
so we take back
okay I take the pawn I take the pun no I
think we're fine now
I think we're fine now I mean again the
way he's playing I'm just you know I'm
losing some confidence after after I
blunder this Knight E4 trick I lost some
confidence but
I think I think we're back in business
here
I think we're back in business yeah he
has me sweating that's for sure
Yeah so basically now
if Queen takes C5 what did we do in that
position because there there is a very
tempting tactical move which doesn't
work and there is a simple move which
does
so what do we do in response to Queen C5
yeah we play it simple we play Queen
takes B7
the tempting move which doesn't work is
actually Rook dd5 I wonder how many of
you saw that possibility
right contact between pieces always a
source of tactics so Rook D5 Bishop
takes D5 Rook takes D5 we're forking the
queen in the night unfortunately black
has a check on C1
so this is a no-brainer we play Queen
takes B7 and we have now still two pawns
and The Rook for the minor pieces
objectively I would evaluate this as
equal
I I think this is close to equal
dynamically but we have great practical
chances because we have a far Advanced
pass pawn and we have excellently placed
pieces and our King is safe that really
is the main thing which is that our King
is safe for the time being
and our goal well we have a couple of
things on the horizon we are of course
checking tactics constantly because Rook
takes Bishop is possible in certain
cases
our overarching priority is to push the
pawn but not if it becomes weaker we
have to push it very carefully
and of course the third thing to keep in
mind is that a rook trade generally
favors the side with the Rook so Rook to
d8 is a possibility if black plays
Knight to C4 in this position probably
we will respond with Rook to d8 because
if black has only one if black has no
Rooks then stopping the passer is going
to be a lot more difficult and the logic
is that when your opponent has only two
minor pieces minor pieces aren't good at
multitasking that's what Rooks are so
good at because it's a long range piece
so if we were to trade a pair of Rooks
then black will have to assign one minor
piece the task of stopping the past
spawn maybe that'll allow us to
transition the focus to the other side
of the board if that makes sense
we are in very much in business also
black is getting
quite low on the clock that's another
two minutes our opponent is spending
oh
oh my gosh we actually had a crazy
tactic there was Rook D5 Bishop takes D5
and then Queen takes E5 that led to a
draw though I think this is our best bet
at playing for a win okay Bishop C8 to
me strikes me as a slightly panicky move
so the other trade that we would like to
initiate is the trade of Queens if the
Queens are traded it's the same logic
black will have a harder time stopping
the passer so from that point of view
what move is on our radar so Queen B6 is
a way to attempt the queen trade but
it's a little bit awkward because it
puts the queen on the Square where we
want the pawn to advance so so is there
another way to offer the queen trade
such that we keep the coordination of
our pieces yeah Queen back to D5 if you
know what you're looking for Queen D5
should be a reasonable move
so if black trades we take back with
even Rook 1 takes D5
and B6 is basically coming next so I
think this is good for white I think
windy five is a very challenging move
practically speaking and black is down
now to five and a half minutes hopefully
he takes a little longer thinking about
this
so I'm already playing a little bit for
the clock here
which I know might cause some people to
roll their eyes but again I'm get trying
to give you a sense of how I would
normally play
and if I saw the my opponent was down to
five minutes I would try to make moves
that pose problem pose actual decisions
okay what Rook do we take with not an
easy question because there's a tactical
detail that has to be factored in
if we take with Rook 1 takes which I
think is the tempting move black plays
Knight to C4
and in that position if we go Rook C6 we
fall into Bishop B7 that skewers the two
Rooks so that that tells us that after
Knight C4 we will have to play Rook to
d8 and I did say that a trade of Brooks
is good for us I'm not totally sure that
that holds true here because the Rooks
are so incredibly active so from that
perspective Rook 6 takes D5 actually
makes some sense because Knight C4 there
no longer comes with Tempo and we can
continue harassing the Knight with
something like Rook C5 that's a hard
question it's a very hard question let
me think about this for a second
I do not know what the right call is I
see a lot of tactics in this line so I'm
gonna go Rook one takes D5
but this is pure purely an intuitive
judgment I didn't do all that much
calculation here
we're gonna take with the Rook one
Knight G6 okay that's a good sign
because black is not stopping us from
going B6 also we could of course go Rook
d8 that's also a possibility but Rook d8
is that going anywhere like Rook d8 is
not going to disappear B6 on the other
hand we might not get another chance to
play so from that perspective B6 is good
what is
black gonna do after B6 so probably he's
gonna go Bishop B7 I would imagine then
Rook can slide over to C5 and we can try
to deploy The Rook on the seventh rank
the downside of that is that black keeps
his Rook
so again it's a big decision to hear
Rook d8
yeah I think from that perspective we
should go Rook d8 yeah I think we should
go Rook d8 because
B again B6 is also not going anywhere
that was the thing I said which was
wrong black can't stop B6 so we take the
opportunity while we can get it now if
black takes on d8 then he loses the
bishop but if black plays something like
F6 we don't need to rush Rook takes f8
then The Rook is not going anywhere we
can probably wait until black brings the
king out and then if necessary take on
f8 Bishop B7 okay
so I guess the move here is Rook dd7
same logic right A lot of people here
would be tempted to take on f8 I'm not
sure that that's the appropriate way to
play because rushing Rook takes f8 helps
black get a piece closer to the queen
side in this case the king or even the
Knight if we play Rook takes f8 Knight
takes f8
then we can't go Rook to D7
which we would like to play
so I think Rook to D7 is the way to go
attacking the bishop not immediately
we're threatening of course to take the
rook and then take the bishop that's why
Knight E5 is bad
no it does not allow Bishop C6 because
the pawn protects that square so that's
not right
now black can take the Rook now and then
block with the Knight but then we swing
The Rook over to B8 we we push the pawn
from behind then we go B6 B7 and once
the pawn reaches p7 if black is a knight
on f8 The Rook takes f8 check is gonna
Force win the game
does that make sense so actually this
might actually happen unless black is
found some way
to deal with the pawn
okay let's be very accurate here because
I think we are on the cusp of winning
this game
and I think if we want to be ultra
accurate
we should throw in a move here let me
think about this
okay so here's what I'm trying to figure
out I was trying to figure out whether
to play B6 here
uh or whether to play this move which
perhaps was not on everybody's radar the
move F3
and the point of F3 is very simple I'm
trying to force this bishop off this
diagonal so that the red carpet is
unrolled for the pawn
but the the worry that I had after F3
was a very strange one it was that black
plays Knight to E5 which is an advanced
move but I'll explain it more after the
game
but now that I've calculated some
variations
I don't think it's that dangerous
anymore
so we're gonna go F3 we're gonna go F3
and try to knock the bishop off of this
diagonal if black plays Bishop to A8
then we play B6 because that Bishop on
A8 is incredibly vulnerable okay 95.
okay
so
the reason I wasn't too scared about
this move is that we can transform our
advantage from one to the other what
does Knight E5 do well it attacks The
Rook
and if we move the Rook we
think that 95 does is it opens up a
retreating Square for the bishop back to
B7 right that's really what it does
so after Rook to D4 black is forced to
play Bishop B7 then I was calculating
Rook takes to f8 King takes f8 we can
play F4 to chase the Knight away Knight
has to drop back to G6 then we move the
Rook back up to D7
Bishop E4 is forced we go B6 and we win
I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure that Rook D4 wins by
force
if I've calculated this correctly Rook
D4 wins by force but we can also play F
take C4 I think a lot of you should see
this move F take C4
and after Knight takes D7 Rook takes D7
white is up two Pawns in that end game
workout game mainly we have this passer
on B5 so that should be a win but if
I've calculated this correctly this move
wins without a fight because we simply
Force black to give up a minor for the
pawn
unless I unless I'm blundering which is
entirely possible
given how the game has transpired so far
if Bishop a a then we take the rook and
we put the other Rook on d8 and we pick
up the bishop is Bishop C2 then already
we play B6 and that has to be game over
oh crap he does have Bishop F3 oh my
gosh I didn't see that
I didn't see Bishop F3
man I'm blundering this game a lot of
blunders
he doesn't see it oh thank God
wow I think Bishop F3 might have been
winning but why risk it yeah three was
completely Escape my mind I didn't do
what I I didn't practice what I preach I
didn't uh
didn't notice the forkable squares at
all like this move escaped my attention
at all because I just kind of assumed
that all pawn end games are winning but
somehow the king and that end game
reaches the pawn which is absurd now F4
now we play F4 so we chase the Knight
away
the Knight has only one squared it only
has G6 only has G6 then we move the Rook
up to D7 again
exploiting the fact that the bishop
can't go to the eighth rank because it
is forked why are we going Rook D7 to
pave the way for the advance of the pawn
which is finally going to move up to B6
we were very patient I'm now I'm very
curious to check Bishop F3
because if it's like it might actually
relinquish the win Rook D4
very sloppy by me very sloppy
yeah that that is just uh inexcusable
sloppiness and
you know sometimes it just happens I've
been
you know it happens to everybody and
people have to realize that you know
sometimes tactically I'm I'm just slower
on some days than on others okay now we
play B6
and this I calculated correctly because
it shows you how bad minor pieces are at
dealing with the uh the combination of a
rook and a pass Pawn like when you've
got a rook in a pass Pawn black would
kill for a rook that would stop the pawn
from B8 this is kind of why trading
Rooks often favors the side with the
Rook
King E8 but now a very important detail
what should we do now
King Y8 is understandable yeah we played
B7 right we use the rook and with its
last at last gasp it supports the
advance of the pawn we promote and we
win
I assume we win this I'm I'm not
confident in anything but
up a pawn
against two minor pieces this is the win
actually I have two examples to show uh
both of them involve minor pieces and
how they work I think it'll help you
increase your understanding of how minor
pieces cooperate
and in general of Rook versus minor
piece positions
Queen 8 and 95 yeah and that idea did
not make it into the course but we'll
check we'll check out how I should have
played here I mean clearly white is up a
pawn and like what is much better but
yeah this this idea escaped me
completely
okay so the best way to win such
positions with the corner of your eyed
you double check that there's no way to
win the minor piece I don't see any ways
to win a minor piece so the second best
thing is to go after your opponent's
pawns right again minor pieces are bad
at defending individual weaknesses
so we actually lift the queen up to G8
careful how you make this move because
all the surrounding squares like
Minesweeper are blocked
okay not a perfect game but sometimes
that makes it more interesting and more
instructive apologies for all the
mistakes in this game
let's start from the opening
so first of all I'm going to pull up the
course just to double check
um a63 C5
dc5 was correct Knight C6 and A3 very
important move
A3
yeah E5 Bishop G5 first we're going to
check the uh game continuation that I'll
show you a couple of Sidelines Bishop E6
B4 Bishop B7
Knight F3 castles Bishop B2 so the
course ends here
Queen E8 is
an incredible move
and according to the engine and white is
better here white is up upon so we ended
the line here normally the course ends a
lot later than move 10 but certain
situations where uh it's clear that one
side is better and queen 8 is the top
move Queen E8 is the top of it would
never occur to me
and Queenie a rook d8 is an unusual idea
and castles isn't indeed a mistake
according to the engine let me tell you
what stockfish 15 recommends here
let me tell you what stockfish 15
recommends here
I'm not going to say never would never
occur to me it it is an understandable
logical move
it just comes out of nowhere
yeah Queen E8
and first of all to understand why Queen
Aid is played if black plays Knight E4
immediately then simply you can play
Bishop takes E7 that's why black moves
the queen away in the game I couldn't
play Bishop E7 because of Knight takes
C3 and there was a queen that used to
stand on d8 here this would work out but
black takes the bishop with check that's
the other problem if this wasn't a check
you would have taken the Rook on f8 and
Y would have been winning
and black would have been forced then to
take on E7 here unfortunately it's a
check and black emerges up a piece
so that was the biggest issue
the best move appearance plus over minus
is Knight to A4 which I wanted to play
initially you actually are supposed to
go Knight to A4 the move that I
mentioned before white is much better
it's 0.7
typically black plays here and the idea
is simple you take the sting out of the
move 90 For You Castle
I think most humans would go 94 here
Bishop takes E7 Queen takes C7 and now a
brilliant idea
uh Eve black plays Knight takes C7 then
the same idea applies
so Black's biggest advantage in a
position like this is his Center so we
use tactics here to chip away at Black
Center we make a move that seems Brazen
but works concretely let's see if
anybody can find it what is White's best
move in this position and I've given you
a bit of a hint
very good this chat is on fire C4 is the
best move very concrete move because
you're giving up a pawn to the
discovered attack but the idea is to
remove the defender on the Knight now
the queen goes to C2 this is not an
atypical idea this I've seen this in
other openings black has to defend the
Knight
and now
um you have to be careful how you take
on C4 because now there's an x-ray
against the queen
so the best move of course is to take
with the queen queen takes C4 and notice
that the Knight guards D2 so black can
still play this move it's the top engine
move actually but we drop our Knight
back to C3 to reinforce the bishop and
black as basically no compensation here
for instance Rook after d8 Rook F2 D1
you now neutralize Flex the last
remaining active piece notice how our
control over the D4 Square that's really
big here because that means the Knight
doesn't have any prospects
so the biggest takeaway is that after
Queen E8 you respond with Knight to A4 a
couple of other important lines after
Bishop to G5
a lot of people here play D4 immediately
including some GMS here you move the
Knight out to A4 this is one of our
important Innovations and if black
delivers this check then after C3 white
is almost winning
why is white almost winning here because
after d takes C3 there's a very
important move if you take back on C3
then black takes C5 black is all right
actually Knight c394 is winning for
black
so you have this Intermezzo B4
connecting the pawns forcing the queen
away and if black sacks on b4s is all in
the course you simply stop the pawn with
Queen C2 black loses C3 and black loses
the game
if black moves the queen
then obviously you can take on F6 first
to ruin the structure and then play
Knight C3 and you're you're much better
or the engine even gives this move and
then you pick up the pawn with the other
Knight the other night comes out to pick
the pawn so
uh so Queen A5 doesn't work and this
analyzed position is analyzed quite
deeply
after before
the main move here
well is Bishop E7 if black plays D4 here
then we take on D4
and if black plays e D4 again we play
Knight A4
and if black tries to chip away at our
Pawn chain we can develop the bishop and
simultaneously pin the Knight preventing
black from taking twice on B4 a b a b
and always we need to develop our King
side efficiently
here we can just continue developing
because if black takes then we take and
we're up a full Pawn again for no
compensation Knight is threatening to
come to B6 white is clearly better
this is one of those lines which occurs
Ultra Ultra often
C5 are supposed to play DC and it's very
hard to come up with the move A3 if you
don't know it some people here will go
E6 here simply black is much worse after
before there's no compensation
whatsoever so E5 is best but it doesn't
solve Black's problems if black plays
Bishop C5
of course this is
uh self-evident here you play Bishop
takes F6
Queen takes F6
well you can play either Queen 65 or
Knight takes D5 I think the simplest is
Knight takes D5
and then you can support the Knight with
C4 white is up a full Pawn
so certain self-evident things are not
in the course but most moves that you
need to understand in order to like gain
a comprehension of the line are in the
course so big big takeaway is Queen E8
poses the threat of 94. that's great to
know but according to the engine black
is only slightly better here so let's
continue looking take Stakes takes takes
hopefully it makes sense why why you
can't like take on F3 here you lose the
piece so you have to take the rook and
black takes with Tempo you have to
eliminate the pawn and we get this
position so first Rook FT1 is pretty
obvious I think E4 is an excellent move
we stuck The Rook on D6 and I think
Queen E7 is an excellent move as well
our opponent is activating his pieces
and we are doing the same Queen H5
preventing Queen G5
H6 another great move we respond by
bringing a rook and so this stage of the
game is very understandable Rook f8 I
think might be unnecessary though I
think our opponent should have gone for
our punts immediately with Queen to F6
I'm not sure Rook f8 H3 changes that
much but surely the lack of a back rank
Luft Square makes things worse for us
here
because here if we do the same thing
after C4
already black has a slightly concerning
move in 95.
and black threatens to take on C4
and after Rook to D4
if black plays Knight takes C4 here he
loses to Rook take C4 and this is not
mate because the Rook drops back
but here black can go the other way
Knight to G4 and this is a big problem
because F2 is hanging you can't play
Queen H4 obviously you can't play F3 so
you have to go back with the Rook but
now black gives a check and black sticks
the queen on B2 double attack
so attacking F2 attacking A3
and if we bring the Rook out black
starts gobbling up our pawns so this
waste of a Tempo allowed us to make some
Luft and that helps us gain the upper
hand in the complications so Queen F6 is
an excellent move I think so is C4 and
here if flag plays Knight E5 already
after Rook D4 black doesn't have this
move that's the key difference so it's
not only the Luft Square it's the fact
that we defend G4 from the knife right
this these are the subtleties that often
decide games at this level that's just
how it works so Queen F6 we play C4
intending B5 this is what I was
expecting our opponent to play
and that's actually what happened sorry
so we respond with Queen H4
Quinn H4 hits the only weakness in
Black's position the E4 Pawn
Queen takes A3 was the serious mistake
this was an impulsive move by our
opponent even though it took him two
minutes I think in this position black
is still slightly better if he takes
this pawn and simply sticks the bishop
on B5
why because this immobilizes our Pawn
chain it doesn't allow us to move pawns
black as an uncontested light skirt
bishop and he's using it uh in order to
freeze the pawn so he would have played
probably this move
and then black would have taken and then
we would have taken and then black would
have taken and the position remains
complicated we can even play this move
according to the engine but this is a
bailout move C6 here is a bailout move
if black takes to the bishop then he
loses Queen B4 but black can also take
with a knight and the idea is to take
and give the Rook back up for the two
pieces and this is a dead draw like four
on three one on zero this is a denture
so
no question that Queen A3 was a serious
mistake because now our pawns are very
very powerful and I think what what our
opponent missed from a distance is that
after the trade and after 95 is played
we take on e4
I think our opponent forgot that in this
version
uh black can't play Knight takes C4
because of Rook takes C6 this is what I
was talking about
and after black takes we take once on E6
once on C4 and we're up two Pawns
turns out according to the engine though
this is mind-boggling there's a better
move here then Queen takes E4 Queen
takes E4 Queen C5 is still equal
according to the engine
can anybody locate if you're watching on
YouTube you should pause and try to find
this move this is a very strong move
which sets up mating threats I didn't
see this idea at all I mean I saw it in
general but not here
Rook d8 yeah Rook D60 d8 and suddenly
you're threatening Checkmate if black
plays Queen C5 you play Rook Cafe black
loses because king f8 queen d8 again
Rook trades when you've got a rook
against minor pieces are so so powerful
Rook d8 traps the queen so black has to
waits to Tempo guarding the Rokon of hit
or block has to take but now you take
with the Rook you force the king to H7
and now this is a check and black starts
to lose everything so probably black has
to reinforce this Rook with the Knight
but now you can play Queen E4 and the
Knight has left the center so if black
plays Queen C5 you can play Rook f8
Knight f8 and queen takes B7 this is the
chief difference black loses
probably the game at this point
if you compare this if you take
immediately
if you go for this line what's the key
difference right here are the knights on
E5 so black has Knight takes C4 hitting
the rook and severing the connection
with the B5 Pawn so black on the next
move can take well now white can play
Rook A6 but clearly this is a much
inferior version for white than the one
we looked at with Rook T8 oh comparison
is a really powerful process that you
can use to understand why certain moves
are played in this case it's to force
the Knight off of E5 also to create the
possibility of a rook trade probably a b
was another mistake I didn't understand
why our opponent did that it undoubles
our pawns and after 95 we still had the
move Rook to d8 perhaps but I think this
move makes a lot of sense here Queen C5
Queen V7 and white is playing completely
without risk because even if white loses
the B5 Pawn it's still a draw four on
three and then a rook against two minor
pieces is typically a drop so at this
point I want to show two examples of the
battle of rook and queen vs minor pieces
to really increase your understanding
particularly of playing with the heavy
pieces The Rook or the queen so here's
one of my favorite games this is not
very well known but it features a really
really classic end game moment
I'm gonna pull up the game in just a
moment I have to find it on chess space
this is the game at kalevsky kaganski
mikolevsky
very very strong GM from Israel he is
also known as a noted chess coach he's
written opening books so definitely a
name to to Revere here he has white
against you know 2300 FM
Okay so
in this position it is white to play
Okay
um okay so what's going on well it's
clearly two Rooks against two minor
pieces in a rook
first thing that white does is follow
the rules why does a very easy clap way
to force the Rook trade and by forcing
The Rook trade white is isolating the
minor pieces so what is white play oops
sorry mikoleski plays Rook to C3 Rook to
C3
this attacks the bishop forces the
bishop to move and now he trades so step
one has been achieved step two is to
make sure that black is as paralyzed as
possible so now he brings the other Rook
to the eighth rank in order to paralyze
the Knight
Bishop has to move Rook goes back to the
seventh rank and the bishop moves back
to essentially an implicit dropper white
can repeat moves now with Rook C8 and
Rook C7 now there's a move here that I
think ninety percent of people would
play and then there's the movement
koleski played which is absolutely
freaking brilliant
okay obviously black species are very
passive the move that 90 of people are
playing probably are thinking about this
move on YouTube is Rook A7 because you
know we see pawns and we take them
Bishop C6 and Rook takes A5 the downside
of this approach is that it finally
opens up a pathway for black to get his
pieces into the game so something like
96 is now possible because the Knight is
no longer pinned now
of course black also attacks D4 probably
white would now play
I don't actually know what white does
now I mean white could play B3 to try to
create a pass spawn on the queen side
but here black plays Knight takes D4 and
clearly you've let black off the hook I
mean you're not even close to creating a
passer and black is going to start
bringing his King into the center
so instead
mikilevski finds a brilliant move some
of you were suggesting Rook C5 it's the
same idea this move has to say I agree
Rook C5 is better than Rook A7 because
here you win the B Pawn and by winning
the B Pawn you leave black with a really
passive a pawn true but still black will
play for instance let me think
maybe F6 okay to open up a pathway for
the king you will take on F6 and take on
B5 and white is probably winning here I
agree but again you've let the minor
pieces get out of their cage and black
has chances because the minor pieces get
active so instead of here's what
michalevsky does and here's how he
arrives at that logic okay what is
Black's next move going to be
if you gave black the move how is black
going to untangle
well you might say well black is going
to move the Knight but no Black's not
going to do that because this is a fork
so in order to be able to move the
Knight black has to get his King off the
eighth rank so that Rook CA wouldn't be
a fork so that you can play Bishop B7 so
Black's next move is G6 and that's the
only way to untangle now we skip a move
black then plays King G7 and only then
black is ready to bring the Knight out
to E6 because now Rook C8 is into check
and the bishop is able to to wiggle out
so mikolasi finds an idea that prevents
black from ever untangling he plays G6
himself
and puts the pawn on pre to three
different Defenders
Knight G6 Rook C8 we know so black takes
to the pawn now the Second Step you have
literally put a weight on the G6 square
but now you need to prevent black from
going G5 and G6 white plays F4
stopping well
stopping G5 here white can even take on
G5 but mikoleski was planning F5 and
black literally can't untangle G6 F6 and
the king is stuck on the eighth rank
which means the Knight is stuck on the
eighth rank which means the bishop is
stuck on the eighth Rank and white can
win this pretty easily here's how the
game actually ended black starts
exhausting his moves
and here's what mikolesky does he
literally waits around until black has
exhausted all of his pawn moves and look
at this position black is in zugzvan
Black has no moves to avoid losing a
minor piece because either you move the
Knight which is what happened in the
game and black lost or you have to move
the king and you lose to a fork if you
move the pawn well black it even white
could even take but F5 is the elegant
move because it really highlights the
extent of White's domination
so the move was G6 and this is why peace
activity always determines the
evaluation in Rook vs minor P situations
here's the second game that I had in
mind and this is queen against two minor
pieces which is what we got at the very
end of our game but I had a game many
years ago that was a lot less clear-cut
uh than the the speedrun game we played
which was just dead winning
this is a very old game of mine
as you can see from 2006 I was 1900
and we reached this very unique end game
Queen two minor pieces and two pawns
against Queen this is a very hard end
game to evaluate is this a draw or is
this a win for black
why are we even discussing this because
white basically has a fortress right
whites both pawns are defended by the
bishop and the King respectively so and
Black's pawns are gap tooth which means
black can't use their pawns to dislodge
White's minor pieces you need to find
some other way let's flip it so we're
facing black
so what I started to do like earlier in
the game is I brought my king to White
side of the board and I didn't know
exactly how that was going to help but I
thought that might be a good start for a
while I was unable to make any progress
and I was unable to make progress for so
long
and this is a draw that I ultimately
gave up hope I was hoping to deliver
some meat but all right my opponent just
like correctly shuffles the pieces but
then
at some point
we repeat and repeat repeat at some
point here my opponent makes a very
sloppy move he plays King F3 he should
have played King to F1 so he lets my
queen into E1 the king hides away on G2
okay then I played King to D2 and now
things are getting serious it's still a
draw but white can play Bishop F5 make a
draw
but my opponent was worried about King
E2 he forgot that the bishop can just
come back to G4 and you know
and and this is a dead draw a black can
not literally cannot get to the F2 Pawn
hopefully that makes sense
but he plays Bishop G4 to D1 and offers
a draw and I suddenly got scared I was
like wait the queen is trapped and I
took a draw Bishop D1 is a losing move
who can tell me why and I analyzed this
for a long time with my coach we came up
with some very cool lines here as far as
we know this is analysis from 2005 this
is a loss no the muppua is Queen takes
D1 remember from the pawn end game
videos it's not about who's King is more
advanced it's about whose King is closer
to the pawns if you think of it that way
you should understand that White's King
is very close to the H4 Pawn this is not
going to be winning this is probably a
draw but I think even black is close to
losing this because this type of okay
it's a draw it's a draw but black draws
by like narrow thread it's not Queen
takes D1 and it's not Queen takes E3
similar reasoning white is going to be
the first to take the pawn
so this is not the right approach
instead you have to notice that the
bishop on D1 is very vulnerable because
it's protected by the Knight the move is
F5 yeah F5
how does F5 help because the bishop of
course can go back let's say to F3
now as far as I remember you're supposed
to play F4
you're supposed to play out for why does
basically two options where is White
gonna go with his Knight well probably
white is going to go to G4 because if
white goes elsewhere the pawn on F2 can
be surrounded you can go like this
and then white is almost in zugzvan
because why there's no moves white has
to go back with his King you can deliver
a check on A1
and basically the bottom line idea is
you like go here and you're trying to go
King E1
you're trying to set up this situation
where the pawn cannot be defended white
can only stop you in one way it's quick
to go King F1 and who can find the most
accurate move in this position let's see
who understands how this end game works
black is a winning move here
how do you clear the way for the king
there's only one correct check Peter per
cherb got it it's Queen to C4 check
because you have to keep the F4 Pawn
protected then you drive your king into
E1 why doesn't zugzvan white has no
pieces to move other than his King and
now Queen F1 is just game over
okay so this is what that means the
white has to sit on G4 because on G4 the
Knight is unassailable and it's
defending F2 but I'm pretty sure the
black is still winning here
how is black winning here let me
try to remember
or is he winning yes black is winning
because
I think what you're supposed to do here
you start with a move like Queen A1 okay
so white has to make some random bishop
move you get in with your king but then
you make this very important move here
you play like Queen to A6 I think I
don't remember how this wins maybe this
is a drop maybe we were wrong let me
check the engine
let me check the engine here this is
interesting enough five but by the way
it shows you how resilient minor pieces
are at holding things together it's like
very very hard to crack these yeah it is
winning it is winning
Bishop F3 oh F4 is wrong I apologize F4
is not the move
the move is Queen to B1
and basically white loses so white makes
a random bishop move
and now you play King to E1
and if light makes a random bishop move
oh you just pick up the pawn on F2 you
don't need to play F4 what am I saying
of course F4 is useless
because ultimately you're gonna push
white off the board check here here
and that's it you're threatening
Checkmate on G1
so white has to move the Knight and give
up the pawn in F2 and there's just
nothing that white can do you just get
in you get into E1 with the King
white has just no other moves if white
gives a check then you get in anyway
and now you go Queen B2 you attack the
pawn White's Knight is no checks like
the king can't be assailed and then you
do this thing where you go king queen
queen G7 and then King F1 to push the
king away it's a cool idea but uh I
didn't see any of that and you couldn't
do that earlier like here
if white waits around with any move
other than Bishop F1 it's harder to get
the king in
because okay you can go Queen C1
you can go here but there is I think ah
the point is white can go like King G1
and then at the right moment Knight G2
check so somehow hear white holds but
with a pawn and F5 black takes away key
squares from the bishop in the night
okay let's move on to the game hopefully
this was
semi-illuminating
it just came to my mind because I
remember the two minor pieces
so
in the game once we played Queen B7 I
could sense that we were close to
winning then we initiated the forced
Queen trade and Knight G6 is another
mistake this is a very very bad move
because now the Knight is passive black
has to go Knight C4 there's no there's
no question that the Knight has to keep
contact with the B6 Square what I was
talking about is this would be very
careless because the bishop B7 and black
wins in exchange
now I want to point something out which
is that if White's Pawn was on e4 if you
had this position this would be fine for
white so don't forget that if you have
Rook versus two minor pieces you can
game the minor pieces again for the Rook
so don't rule out lines where you lose
your Rook if you win both minor pieces
of course here we don't have the pawn on
e4 so that doesn't work
so after Knight G6 Rook d8 okay the game
is over
but now of course I made a horrible
mistake F3 is correct 95 is correct up
yeah Rook D4 is a big mistake it's still
winning after Bishop F3 is still winning
was just to take the rook and go Rook C7
and then promote the pawn I don't
understand why I didn't play this
but this ends the game immediately
yeah Rook Cafe and Rook C7 I don't know
I was somehow fixated
on forcing black to be the one to take
because I was obsessed with the idea of
forcing the king in the other direction
somehow I didn't like
realize that the king is still too far
away from the pawn but Rook D4 would win
if it weren't for Bishop F3 apparently
the winning move here the only winning
move and let me explain why the pawn end
game is drawn the reason the pawn end
game is drawn first of all is because
the king catches the b-pawn so you have
the gap tooth Pawn formation which is
self-sufficient the king can't take
either of the pawns that's fine so you
get this situation black skin has to
shuffle between D7 and D6 the problem is
that black is a three on one on the
queen side and white cannot defeat a
three on one with his King Alone
like black will play here and then here
and you have literally no way even like
F4 you have no way to make progress
because this is a protected past Pawn
does that make sense so this is just a
dead draw on Pawn end game the move
apparently is E4 you have to cut off the
bishop you have to cut off the bishop
and on the next move you play B6 Bishop
B2 actually no apparently you throw in
Rook D5 first to hit the Knight now you
play B6
okay so you're threatening B7 okay so
black has to stop the pawn now you
deliver a check you go around to A8 oh
wow and black can't go here because of
Rook A7 beautiful so you're forcing the
bishop away and now you promote to upon
you Force black to give up his Knight
by the way I see this mistake so often
if black plays Knight C6 here who can
tell me what the best move is for white
is it to promote the pawn this is an
advanced mistake I see very very often
Rook see it yeah Rook CA wins on the
spot because you actually give up The
Rook for the night and you promote to a
queen so don't automatically promote
when your opponent is stopping the minor
Pawn the pawn of the minor piece see if
you can essentially capture the minor
piece because then you can promote the
entire Pawn
after Knight D7 black white doesn't have
the same option
because the Knight can't be a sale but
this is winning this is theoretically
winning end game but it would some work
would still be required for us to win
this and definitely there was no need to
blunder this these can be very very hard
to win like three on three
can be very very hard to win
so definitely this should not have been
allowed
you want to hear something crazy so do
you remember I said you throw in this
move why not B6 immediately here's the
difference so here you get the same line
rookie eight black blaze Bishop D sorry
black plays
no here apparently black plays some sort
of weird King E7 oh and if you start
with Rook D5
in this position there is no King E7
because here you can take the Knight and
play B7 so you're forcing Bishop A6
whereas there there's some tricky King
E7 move so many of these subtleties
these types of positions amazing just as
honestly amazing okay after our opponent
played Bishop B7 the only critical move
was F4 forcing the Knight away to look
at the domination C6 control D7
controlled C4 controlled the Knight has
to drop all the way back and bang Rook
D7 again domination Bishop can't go back
to the eighth and we will go B6 and B7
is going to decide 97 Rook d8 is
Checkmate by the way don't forget this
mating pattern even with the King on f8
it's still possible to back rank me
B7 and that's it B8 Queen is happening
of course this is technically nominally
more resilient but four on three plus an
extra exchange is easy win you just get
your king up and then you basically just
push your pawns to Oblivion this is
super super straightforward winning
process here
okay so takeaways from this really
excellent game first of all huge go to
Star opponent for finding this Queenie
in 94 idea so the opening was a jabalon
and I want to remind people I have a
course on this opening that will be
linked in the description
um that I released together with Jam
Alexander Bortnick so this follows the
course this all follows the course my
biggest mistake was not to ask what my
opponent wanted with this movement in
fact I asked what he wanted I thought he
wanted Rook d8 so the correct move here
is to preemptively move the Knight away
from an undefended Square
and to take the sting out of the move 94
that would have given white a clearly
better position instead once we
blundered the two pieces for a rook
black was better but we did our best to
activate our pieces
we found resilient moves all the way
through and the critical mistake for
black black made a couple of mistakes
first of all Rook f8 was a waste of time
the immediate Queen F6 would have been
very problematic for us
this allowed us to make Luft and then
the main mistake that black played is to
take the pawn on A3 black should have
taken the other Pawn when you have the
minor pieces Against The Rook your top
priority should basically be to to hold
off your opponent's Pawn Mass because
once the pawn mass starts rolling Rooks
are really really good at supervising
past pawns so you want to keep things
immobilized as much as possible
any questions
[Music]